hey friends over the years i've got
quite a few requests to do a video where
i show off my
collection of plucked instruments so
here we go
now without a doubt this next guy is one
of my prized possessions
this is a fiorbo
made in london by klaus jacobson it's a
really fantastic
instrument and as you can see it is
currently folded in half which is pretty
impressive
he invented this
mechanism
which allows the instrument
to fold because it's actually just like
my arch loot it's like six feet long so
it unfolds into its full
you know scale length which is as tall
as me but then it's so conveniently the
strings to fold up
back in half which means it can easily
fit in a case which is about the size of
a guitar case
and probably the most amazing part is
the mechanism here
it allows us to stay in tune because the
strings stay under tension and that is
just i think ingenious
then a little fake peg here
goes in so the neck can't collapse
and then you pull out this
little
piece here
and now we have the full the full
instrument
this instrument is so satisfying to play
that low
thump of those gut strings sounds so
good when i bought it actually it wasn't
a folding instrument he made it without
the folding mechanism but then i had him
pick it up
and
he chopped it
added the
the folding mechanism onto which i
really wanted and i happened to be
touring in england at the time and he
has a shop in london and so we met at
the airport and he handed off the
instrument unfortunately the whole thing
was really rushed i really wanted to get
to know him
but i just had to grab it and get on my
flight because it was about to leave
so because of the folding mechanism i
was able to simply very easily fit into
a seat next to me
and i've had it ever since and loved it
another one of my favorites the baroque
guitar
this is the predecessor of the modern
six single string guitar that we know
today i bring this instrument along with
me when i play operas and chamber music
and continuo just like the orbo so a lot
of my broke gigs are a theorbo in one
hand and i broke guitar another and i'm
constantly switching back and forth
depending on what type of sound i want
to make if in that moment in the opera i
need a deep bass sound with lots of
thick rolled chords i pull out the
fjorbo and if it's a dancy song that
needs more of a strummy
uh sound then the guitar is perfect for
that so the two of those together make a
really nice baroque gigging kit
out of all my guitars this is one of my
most sentimental uh instruments because
this is one of the
guitars that i had made for me custom
back in 2016 i commissioned luthier in
maliga spain named julio costano soler
who is a fantastic builder of
baroque guitars and vuelas
and he was recommending me recommended
to me by so many different professional
players and so i went to stay with him
for a few days and they were so nice to
me him and his wife mariana are
wonderful people hi guys if you're
watching um
and i just love this guitar um it is
built uh with this another rose design
here with three-dimensional rows which
goes deep into the instrument sometimes
we call it a like a reverse wedding cake
rose then again of course you have the
movable movable frets
the pegs which are on the back of the
headstock this time instead of the sides
baroque guitars have the hourglass shape
indicative of guitars and a flat back
rather than that round back that we saw
with a lot of the loops so it really is
like you know the instrument that comes
right before we get the single string
guitar that we all know today
[Music]
if you've been following my youtube
channel for any length of time you will
have heard this instrument quite often
all of my cds and most of my videos have
been recorded on this which is my only
other instrument that i've ever had
actually uh custom-made for me this is a
2010 steven kagos guitar stephen caicos
is a luthier in minneapolis minnesota
it's one of the best guitars i've played
personally
and i would highly recommend stephen
caicos if you're interested in
having another classical guitar or
having your first classical guitar even
built for you i had this built for me in
2010 right when i was starting my first
degree in classical guitar
i showed up to my degree with a
less than ideal
guitar a classical little tar that was
really
it looked pretty but it was mostly shiny
finish with pretty mother-of-pearl
inlays um it was a guitar that i picked
up at guitar center
nothing wrong with guitar center but in
terms of professional concert
classical guitars it's not really the
ideal place to go
um and i quickly found out when i showed
up to my degree that it wasn't cutting
it so
i had this made and i've been so happy
with it ever since it has a flame maple
back inside which is just so so
beautiful and it's so easy to play
currently i have gut strings
on
which sounds so good i have nails again
at the moment and even with nails
the gut strings sound fantastic
[Music]
a while back i also picked this guy up
this is a cordoba ukulele
[Music]
and uh
actually it sounds quite good i think
for the price i picked this up because i
was teaching some ukulele around town
and i wanted my own instrument to teach
but actually i kind of fell in love with
it and i really get why
ukuleles are making a comeback at the
moment they're quite trendy but you know
i think people think about them only as
a self-accompanying
simple instrument but
i mean it's just basically like a
renaissance guitar
which has lots of solo repertoire for it
and you can do a lot of really cool
things on it
[Music]
you know you can do strumming you do
tremolo
it's basically a small guitar right and
so i think let's not undervalue the
power of a ukulele so i'm happy to have
one sitting around to have fun with
sometimes my next instrument is one that
surely doesn't get enough love
this one is the chirongo
i got this about maybe 10 years ago
there was a gig i was asked to play
where
they wanted me to play chirongo with a
choir
basically the toronto is native to
bolivia i believe and there was a
an argentinian composer named ariel
ariel ramirez who wrote a piece called
the misa crayola which i'm sure i'm
mispronouncing and yeah there was like
this folk band next to a choir and they
wanted me to play chorongo so i learned
this instrument then haven't really used
it much since
um normally tarango's have a armadillo
shell for a back this one i'm happy to
say is just made of wood
and other than that it's kind of like a
little guitar right uh all the strings
are doubled
surprised like a lot of my other
instruments um and then we have actually
gears
uh so not the pegs on the on the loots
and things and then of course metal
frets just like
guitars and this instrument is tuned
very high
it has five pairs of strings which are
tuned to this kind of
strange inside outside tuning the third
string is the same
as the first string
but the third has an octave on it
[Music]
this is a really fun instrument and i
would love to give it more attention
[Music]
now back in high school i picked up this
kirk hammett signature guitar and it got
a lot of love for maybe
four or five years uh and then i got
into classical avatar and i barely
touched it
so uh over the last 10 years or so it's
really been unfortunately just
collecting dust and this is actually one
of the instruments that is also for sale
at the moment i posted about that by the
way and so many people wrote like don't
sell it no
but you know i have lots of guitars and
i'm constantly buying and selling to to
make room for for new ones so i'm gonna
let this baby go but
uh it's really been a cool guitar to
have um
with all the you know the whammy bar
features you can do the floyd rose
system the emg 81 pickups which are
really rocking the skull and crossbone
inlays it's a really fantastic guitar
for metal playing and i did a lot of you
know high school shredding on it
but since then you know uh priorities
change and unfortunately yeah i haven't
been giving it the love it deserves
[Music]
now the two oldest instruments in my
collection are from when i was around 11
with my first guitar and this bass which
actually was my older brother's and i
think i just stole it from at some point
both by ibanez or ibanez is probably
pronounced
they are both instruments we got from
our local music store uh when we started
playing so long ago and there they're
the instruments that really kicked off
my brothers and i uh with our musical
you know playing and uh i promised to
never sell that first guitar that i
that one is too sentimental um but it's
yeah it's sitting in my high school
bedroom uh right now it's not a great
guitar but uh i think i'll keep it just
because
it was my first you know and this space
my older brother isn't playing it
anymore so
it's currently my possession and
sometimes i i jam on it i've also used
it for a couple cool gigs that i've got
hired for um the composers of the famous
musical les mis les miserables
they wrote another musical in the 70s
called the french revolution and it
premiered in chicago that was the
american premiere of it and i was lucky
enough to play some base with my twin
brother in it and so this has got some
love
but again mostly unfortunately this sits
in the closet
collecting a whopping amount of dust
so that's it for my personal collection
i do have a bunch of other miscellaneous
instruments percussion instruments brass
instruments things that i've got from
traveling that are on my on my wall just
for fun but i don't really play them
they're more you know for beauty uh then
i have a bunch of other instruments that
i've sold in the past that i used to use
and i'm kind of i'm constantly changing
my collection so maybe one of these days
i'll make another video if i have enough
new and different instruments but for
now thank you so much for watching
please do subscribe if you haven't
already and if you want to support this
channel you can do so by becoming one of
my patrons on patreon and lastly there
is a big discount going on at my online
music school our pajato so if you
haven't signed up yet for lessons and
are interested in lessons on guitar
ukulele bass food whatever we have
teachers for all those and we're
offering a huge 20 discount on your
first four packs so
check that out and i'll see you guys
next time later
[Music]
you